I hate Thai food I love Thai food
this looks like an egg sandwich it's
like a little taco it tastes exactly
like a fortune cookie oh it's got it oh
it's like got a tangy orange flavor is
it coconut is it color coconut I know it
smile I'm not a big fortune cookie fan I
know that's ironic but I'm not happening
what's going on here I think we're gonna
eat unicorn hair whoo interactive
desserts Thai people are all about the
tacos I think I just poked one up my
bills I'm really sorry
Cheers oh this is fun like it melts in
your mouth the same way cotton candy
does I feel like Rumpelstiltskin like
turn it to gold no this is it
phallic right what a story it's the
thing that smells really bad not
advertising this ah ha ha Wow
no it smells like mango plus throw up oh
it tastes great it's like a gummy bear
that's turned evil okay it does taste
better than it smells
it's like a very tame version in this
mountain this is a pancake all right I
love taro boba it smells like a donut oh
dear I'm so good ah okay shuck corn
listen may as well tell it to parents is
dropping out of high school because it
is disappointing me it's like an all
enjoy without the chocolate or the nut
and with purple looks like salted poop
look at these little turds oh that's
hard feed there's a seed wait what is
going on is it spicy is it sweet Wow
Oh oppa now I'm kinda into it okay it's
a salty immersed and sweet and enzymes
bite are you that's dessert is supposed
to be a treat after dinner this is like
a whole new afternoon for a joyride it
said get in shut up
cuz I'm driving this looks like lunch
not dessert you have to work for your
dessert in Thailand
what what in there it is a baby alien do
it oh there is banana in here this is a
mush of banana inside of rice ah oh
mmm I like that it's like rice pudding
except a gummy bar whenever you have
anything that looks like a taco or a
burrito you're killing it Thailand
not the biggest fan of the spices I am
really wowed to talk
nothing like Thailand they'll be talking
about Thailand so good oh good so again
yeah are you supposed to eat this word I
actually don't know you want to you're
probably not supposed to eat